ينضم الي من القاهره السفير حسام زكي
الامين العام المساعد لجامعه الدول
العربيه سعاده السفير اهلا بك معنا اذا
اردنا ان نعلق على ما يجري في السودان وما
هي الجهود لوقف هذا العنف الحاصل بين
الاطراف العسكريه في السودان
اهلا بحضرتك طبعا هذا الموقف مؤسس للغايه
وصدر عن عن الجماعه صباح اليوم طبعا
رد فعل
يعني ينشد الاطراف بوقف التصعيد وحقن
الدماء واعلنا ان هناك استعداد من جانب
الامانه العامه للتدخل في هذا الامر اذا
وافق الطرفان
لاستعاده الهدوء طبعا
اي موافقه من الطرفين ام لا جواب حتى الان
يعني اكون صريح معك هذه المناشده اصدرناها
عبر الاعلام التواصل الان تواصل صعب
للغايه يعني يصعب انه يحصل تواصل اللي هو
التواصل المعتاد
للقيادات في الطرفين لكن المناشده
اصدرناها اعلاميا لعلها تصل الى الاخوه في
الجانبين ويعلقوا عليها ولكن ما يهمني هنا
ان اشدد عليه هو
ضروره وضع مصلحه السودان في المقام الاول
المساله
لا تتعلق
للقوات المسلحه فقط ولا قوات الدعم السريع
فقط هناك دوله السودان التي يعني الجميع
يريدها والجميع يريد ان تحافظ على وحدتها
وسيادتها واستقلالها
والكل يرغب في ان يرى هذه الدوله على
المسار الصحيح ما يحدث الان لا يضعها على
المسار الصحيح بل على العكس وهو يعني يهدد
وحده هذا البلد
ويضع عرقيل كثيره جدا امام اعاده تكوينه
لمستقبله الذي كنا جميعا نستبشر به خيرا
تتحدث عن انكم جاهزون لاي وساطه هل هناك
من اي افكار من اي مبادره جاهزه لدى جامعه
الدول العربيه لتطرحها على الاطراف
المتصارعه وهل من ضمانات ممكن ان تقدموها
حتى يتوقف هذا العنف الان
من المبكر الحديث عن
شيء جاهز يطرح على الاطراف من المبكره
الحديث عن هذه المطلوب الان هو تجميد
الموقف ووقف التصعيد لانه استمرار التصعيد
يذهب بنا الى مرحله من الحرب ربما تاخذ
يعني وقتا طويلا والجميع فيها خاسر لن
يكون فيها اطراف يعني منتصره المنتصر فيها
مهزوم
فالامل هنا هو وقف التصعيد اما الحل
الامثل وطويل الاجل والذي يعطي الاستقرار
للدوله السودانيه فهذا امر
سبق وان بحثه السودانيون ومستعدون ايضا
للمساعده في هذا الامر لانه امر مرتبط
بالوضع السياسي العام ومرتبط بالقوى
المدنيه السياسيه المشاركه في السياسيه
فهذا امر له ارتباطات عديده
نسعى الان الى هدف محدد وهو وقف التصعيد
ووقف اطلاق النار والعوده بالامور الى
مرحله من الهدوء ساعات السفير قلت بانه من
الصعوبه الان التحدث الى الاطراف
المتصارعه ولكن هل يتم الحديث او هل يتم
الاتصال ببعض الاحزاب المتواجده داخل
السودان والفاعله والتي حقيقه ايضا تقوم
بتقديم مبادرات وتناشد بوقف هذا العنف
[موسيقى]
بشكل بشكل سريع ولكن لا نفقد الامل ونظل
نحاول ان نطالب الطرفين بشتى الطرق سواء
بطرق مباشره او طرق غير مباشره منها مثلا
عن طريق الاعلان انه الاطراف تتراجع او
تجمد من يعني نصبها العسكري حتى لا يتسبب
التصعيد في المزيد من التصعيد وبالتالي
تصل الامور الى ما لا تحمد عقبه اشكرك
سعاده السفير حسام زكي الامين العام
المساعد لجامعه الدول العربيه ونامل طبعا
هذه المناشده التي اطلقتها عبر شاشه
العربيه نامل ان تلقى اذاننا صاغيه وايضا
تسبب وقف هذا العنف المتصاعد داخل السودان
شكرا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات